Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Richard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. George Boss. He is
Lever Holmer early career fellow at Queen Mary University
of London, and today we're going to talk about
his book Marx and the Politics of Need. So
Dr. Boss, welcome to the show. It's a pleasure
to everyone.
Oh, thank you very much for having me. It's
great to be here.
OK, so before we get into the Marxian aspect
of your book and your work, tell us first,
what are the needs from the perspective of political
science?
Yeah, uh, thank you about that, and I think
the interesting thing about needs uh is. As a,
as an object of like political science study, they
are treated as these kind of um external realities
that we know or discover via one research method
or another, right? So we use some sort of
um empirical inquiry usually to discover what needs are.
And then once they are discovered, needs then kind
of bear in some way on our politics. So
we find out the facts of needs, and that
tells us, tells us sort of how our politics
ought to operate or ought not to operate in
one way or another. And there's very different approaches
which are various different approaches to, to doing that,
which I think we'll get into, but ultimately the
kind of key thing across a lot of political
science and political theory is this idea that needs
are these kind of uh standards or realities external
to our politics that kind of bear on it
from the outside.
Right, but how are needs usually approached? I mean,
not only in political science, but also in other
areas. I mean, uh, what are the different approaches
to how we understand or should understand needs out
there?
Yeah, OK, so I mean I think the, the,
the core thing is understood as these kind of
external facts, that the general. Inquiry around human needs
is trying to identify kind of what these facts
are. And and the, the problem that kind of
theorists tend to face here is that. That beyond
the kind of very, very minimal set of needs
orientated around our kind of bare human survival. We
have to understand what we need related to some
sort of standard around a kind of decent or
minimally good human life. And so we have to
kind of build up from this, this kind of
very minimalistic picture of what needs are. But as
soon as we start doing that, we get into
kind of controversial issues that reach into kind of,
kind of bedrock of different kinds of moral and
political perspectives on the world. I mean, a classic
example in needs theory is questions like autonomy. Um,
YOU know, is autonomy something that should be part
of our kind of very basic understanding of what
needs are for everyone, or are they associated from
more critical perspectives with a kind of distinctly liberal
conception of the good life? And so we get
these kinds of disagreements, and so, kind of responding
to this, this idea that we need this kind
of wider conception of what needs are, but that
we enter these controversies. And these theorists have tend
to approach it in one of two main ways,
really, in the kind of broadest sense historically. And
that's to kind of either focus on a very
thin picture of what needs are based on something
like basic survival, or, or to sort of specify
needs in a really, really abstract way that kind
of apply across lots of contexts. Or to get
these kind of thicker conceptions of need that apply
in a specific context, um, related to culture or
a particular way of life or something like that.
But what would you say are the most prominent
theories of needs in political theory specifically? I mean,
what are the ones that are usually the most
debated that most people agree with, let's say, and
so on.
Yeah, good. OK, so, I mean, uh, one of
the chapters, sort of early chapters in the book
talks about kind of surveys the existing debate on
needs. It's encountered this problem about disagreements over needs
and about the kind of fundamental conflicts. So, and
this tends to be kind of three main ways
in which people have tried to approach these problems.
One is to say that there is just sort
of facts of human needs that we can discover
via reason or some other empirical method. And so
there just are this kind of universal truths of
basic human needs, um. Another says, well, You know,
we recognize this difference in arguments over needs, but
there's nonetheless something like an agreement or an overlap
between these different positions. And if we can identify
something like a consensus between these different positions, we
can then build a kind of theory of need
from that overlap. Yeah. The third perspective, which is
probably closest to where I come from, is. To
say, well, look, actually these disagreements are fundamental and
there's no way around them, and what we actually
need to do is to make sure that these
disagreements are conducted in the best way possible. And
if we are going to disagree, we need something
like legitimate political processes or some way of kind
of working out these arguments despite the fact that
we disagree. And so those are the sort of
three broad camps that the book kind of speaks
to.
But uh I mean, do you think there's any
particular way of perhaps determining whether one of those
approaches is better, and, and of course what we
mean by better in this particular case we can
discuss that is better than the others. I mean,
could we solve that or resolve that through uh
empirical data or is it more of a Philosophical
debate and then if it's philosophy or if it's
political theory, uh I, I, I mean in what
ways could we solve the question. So what, what,
what do you think would be if there's a
an approach here to really figuring out which of
these different approaches is the best, um, I mean
what would it be?
Yeah. And I think, I think the way you,
you put it, Ricardo, is, is, is very apt
in the sense that sort of solving this problem,
and that has been the general approach across these
three theories, is to say, well, look, we've got
this problem here that we need to solve in
one way or another, and it's that we need
these theories, but that we have this disagreement. And
there's different ways people have tried to approach it.
They've tried to use kind of logical reasoning and
say, well, look, we can reason our way through
these disagreements to some. Kind of factual answer, or
they've used empirical data to say, well, we can
try and identify an overlap. So there's been a
variety of different approaches, but they're all orientated towards
this idea that there is a kind of a
problem here to solve in one way or another.
Um, TO, to a lesser extent, that third one
I mentioned, which we'll maybe come back to, but
ultimately it's this attempt to kind of solve this
problem. And that's effectively, and I don't know if
you want me to, to get into it at
this point, Roberto, but that's effectively where the book
tries to step in and says, well, what all
of this has got wrong is that we actually
shouldn't be. Trying to solve this issue. These point
to something fundamental about needs themselves, the political nature
of needs, and that rather trying to kind of
solve these disagreements or work around them in one
way or another, we need to build our theories
from the facts of these disagreements.
Right, so yeah, we'll come back to that later
then. Uh, BUT which kinds of uses of the
concept of need would you say, uh, have normative
implications? I mean, because it could, we could just
try to. Approach this from a descriptive standpoint, right
and point that there's these different ways that people
can understand needs and uh that's it, and I
mean we could just ignore or don't care or,
or even theoretically. I think that no normative forces
would derive from whatever way we conceptualize need, right?
But I mean, do you think that there are
users of this concept that generate necessarily those normative
forces?
Yeah, I mean, I think there's 22 related questions
in what you asked about. One is sort of
one part of the problem with needs talk in
general is it's very, very elastic and that there's
many, many senses to the language of need. Um,
WE can use needs in, in, in, in non-
normative ways where I can see some, say something
like the remote control needs batteries, and that has
like no normative connotation whatsoever. But there is this
sense of need that people do use in their
daily life, which is to say something like we
have a need, and it's that kind of noun
structure that there is a clue, it's not perfect,
but it's a clue to this struc you know,
we talk about a need for water or a,
a, a need for food. Um, AND I think
that, that, you know, one way people have historically
approached needs is to say, because of all this
mess, because of all these disagreements, because of all
these different senses of the language which are very
hard to unpick. We should just avoid the language
altogether and we should just not talk about needs,
and you get this, for instance, in some sort
of um economistic approaches which say, you know, think
that, um, there's a sort of famous quotation that,
that needs are just desires that people don't want
to pay for. Um, AND, you know, we could,
we could do that, we could go down that
normative route when other people have recommended it for
different reasons, but another sort of point that the
book starts from is to say, well, actually, look.
Needs are in our politics. Our political processes are
full of needs talk, um, and we have to
start from the recognition of that fact, right? I
mean, you know, the number of state, uh, actions
and policy areas where needs talk seems to be
kind of intimately interwoven with what the state's doing,
you know, any welfare state provision, education, and then
we can think about sort of crises like the
pandemic, a lot of book was written in the
pandemic. So needs are just there, um, and so
we have to deal with the fact that needs
are just there and there are certain usage of
that term around this idea of a kind of
a need, um, that, that do seem to have
this kind of political and moral force.
Right, but er I mean, why is it that
at least some people tend to talk about needs
as moral facts that sort of sit outside of
politics?
So why, why do people do that?
Yeah, uh, or, or how and why, actually,
yeah. How, why? I mean, I, I think, I
think this is the two answers to that why
question really, and one of them is to say
it's precisely this kind of appeal to kind of
something like necessity or something beyond our current state
of affairs or, or, or something that's kind of
beyond political disagreement or beyond differences between something, something
that's necessary in some way. And it's this idea
of a. NECESSITY is deeply interwoven with these kind
of normative senses of needs. Like, it couldn't be
otherwise. Um, WE simply must have it, there's no
way around it. And so it's precisely because it's
that sense of need that has, uh, a moral
connotation that people do try to reach for this
extra political sense. Um, THERE'S also a more Marxian
answer, which maybe we'll get into later, but, you
know, another way to think of it is, you
know, our ways of life make things appear very,
very necessary and feel like they are necessary to
our very self and our survival and our existence
and any kind of minimal decency, when in fact
that is part of our particular way of life.
Um, AND I won't go on in case this
is something we were gonna come to you later,
Roberto, but I'm happy to, to, to talk more
about that.
Yes, but before we get into the understanding of
or an understanding of needs from a Marxian perspective,
we've already touched here on the most prominent approaches
to needs in political theory. So what would you
say are perhaps the main issues and limitations with
them?
Yeah, and I, and I touched on it very
briefly earlier, which is, you know, in all of
them in different ways, try and get around what
we might think of as the politics of need
or the political problem of need, which is, you
know, this idea that in order to have this
kind of moral force, we have to reach beyond
politics. And so they try and find ways to,
to, to, to do that, and, and, and exactly
how we've, we've talked about a little bit. But
I see this as, as, um, problematic in, in,
in two ways. One is conceptually. There's just been
a, a, a, a, a failure to identify this
ground, that there are conceptual problems with each of
these different ways that end up encountering these kind
of fundamental disagreements over what it is to lead
a flourishing or minimally decent life. And so they,
that ultimately these approaches fail. Politically as well, these
approaches are quite, at least dangerous, not always bad,
but certainly dangerous, and that by sort of simply
saying these are facts that sit outside our politics,
we end up. Kind of licensing different kinds of
paternalism, telling people what they need from the outside
and, and actually kind of entrenching existing power structures
by treating things as kind of natural facts when
actually we need to subject them to critical scrutiny.
So when it comes to Marxian approach to needs,
one thing that you do in your book is
that you talk about how the concept of need
in Marxism has been interpreted in different ways, and
then you give us Your reinterpretation of this concept
from a Marxian perspective. So could you tell us
first what are some of the most prominent ways
that it has been interpreted from a Marxist perspective?
Yeah, absolutely. And, and I, and I, and I,
here again, I sort of split things into three
camps. So, the first camp would be something like
an essentialist perspective on needs, which, which fits in
with that kind of idea of a there are
just facts about basic human needs. And this is
often associated with kind of humanist versions of Marxism
or or. Kind of versions of Marxism that emphasize
the kind of ethical and moral role of the
concept of needs in Marx, um, and in particular
focusing on, on his theory of alienation, right? And
so that, that's one camp. Um, A second camp
focuses on needs as just kind of psychological drives
or strongly felt desires. And this camp tends to
be associated with, um, kind of scientific versions of
Marxism. Which say that Marx, at a certain point
in his life, kind of departed from all this
ethical, moral stuff and just focused on developing a
kind of science of history or kind of economic
theory of capitalism. Um, AND so to take out
all the moral stuff, they just say, well, look,
it's just an empirical thing about how people feel.
The third version kind of draws a link between
Marx and Hegel and says that needs are, are,
are dialectical in nature in the sense that, um,
we have a dialectical relationship between human need, our
labor, and, and the natural world. So we feel
needs because we feel needs or have needs, we
labor on the world to meet those needs. In
laboring on the world, we transform that world, we
build things, we cut down trees and so on.
But in transforming the transforming the world, we also
end up change, changing ourselves because we are part
of that natural order. And that sets off new
needs, creating this kind of historical cycle of changing
needs, ultimately leading to a kind of utopian end
in something like communism. So those are, are broadly
the three camps, though there's lots of disagreements and
variants within those as well.
Yeah, sure, but, uh, in your reinterpretation of the
Marxian concept of need, I mean, do you draw
from any one of those earlier interpretations or not?
Um, NOT particularly. I mean, I try and depart
from them a little bit and I think the
sort of common issue I, I, I, I take
across them. Um, IS that in each of them,
they're, they're trying to rescue Marx as some sort
of theoretician, as I, as I call it, uh,
as a, as a philosopher, or as an economist,
or as ultimately sort of turning his theory into
a single kind of theoretical object. And there's lots
of complex historical reasons about why people have tried
to do this with Marx, tied in with the
history of the Marxist movement and lots of interpretive
questions. But for all of these, they sort of
extract Marx from his particular context and try and
develop Marxism as a kind of theoretical approach to
needs. Whereas my reading of Marx focuses much more
on his kind of on the ground political activity
and his political activism. Um, YOU know, Marx was
never a kind of professional academic like me, um,
or many of these people writing these other theories.
Marx was a political agitator, Marx was a social
critic. Marx suffered lots of political oppression and. You
know, we have to look at his writings more
in those engaged political contexts rather than trying to
turn it into this kind of broad theory.
Mhm. So tell us more then about how you
reinterpret the Marxian concept of it. I mean, and
apart from what you've just said, are there, uh,
what are the other ways that your reinterpretation differs
from those other earlier interpretations that we've talked about
here.
So I think my, my version of the sort
of Mark's story of needs, uh, probably follows from
two main moves. One is to emphasize that needs
are, are the products of a particular social system
and historical state of affairs, so they're kind of
social historical. Um, RATHER than being something that kind
of sits outside society and explains how society is,
or that we use to judge such society, we
kind of reverse that order and say, well, actually,
our existing social and historical order explains what our
needs are. Um, THAT, that move is, is, is
different from some of the others in, in, we
can talk a little bit more about that, but
I think the second move is probably the most
distinctive in that not just, uh, the, the idea
is not simply that those processes are social and
historical, but that they're also fundamentally political. In the
sense that these processes by which we go from
our social historical system to needs are political processes.
They involve power, struggle, um, they have kind of
political benefits and burdens that are distributed differently across
a particular population. And so once we look at
those processes as fundamentally political, we open up new
doors to different kinds of contestation and kind of
critical scrutiny on what our needs are, how they
are made the way they happen to be. And
so as I described them in the book, I
think what's distinctive about this way is it emphasizes
the nature of needs as political all the way
down.
Right, so those earlier interpretations, according to them, in
needs from a Marxist perspective were not necessarily constitutively
political, is that it?
Yeah, and I think there's sort of different levels
of politics involved in these different. Visions in a
kind of humanist or essentialist approach, they just sit
outside of politics in much of the way we've
talked about already, from a kind of psychological approach,
they're just facts. Again, that loses some of the
kind of political interests, and they're more just sort
of the, you know, the things that just happen
under capitalism. There's no necessarily any kind of normative
judgment there. The third Agalian approach has been kind
of credited by lots of people as saying, well,
actually this creates a kind of political opening, potentially,
because there are social processes of construction here. But
where a lot of people have come in to
criticize that is, is this kind of um teleological
or utopian element which says, well, ultimately what we're
aiming for here is this kind of system of
needs that arises under communism that's gonna kind of
fix all these problems. Um, AND again, that's kind
of reaching towards another kind of political closure. So
I think what my reading tries to do is
to say, well, look, rather than trying to find
some point in Marx where all the politics stops,
we can finally get on with some normative work.
What happens if we just emphasize the politics on
the ground within a political social order as key
to understanding his interpretation and his text? So that's
what I try and do across the book.
Uh, IN the book you also draw from Wittgenstein's
work, right? So in what ways can his work
also inform an approach such as yours to Ns?
Oh, yeah, and, and I make a couple of
parallels with different figures that came after Marx, um,
including Wittgenstein, and, um, there's an interesting kind of
Marx-Wittgenstein scholarship out there that I draw from. Um,
AND I think the key thing is that both
Marx and Wittgenstein in my reading, share this view
that we, we can't adopt any kind of philosophical
view from nowhere. Um, YOU know, one of the
things that Marx famously, you know, is famously credited
as saying is, uh, you know, consciousness is a
social product. Um, AND one of the, the chapters
in the book is consciousness is a social product,
but even for philosophers. And the, the idea there
is simply to say that one of Marx's key,
uh, stages of intellectual development was to recognize that
all thought, including theoretical thought, and importantly, his own
theoretical thought, was a product of a particular social
and historical order. And there was no way of
stepping outside that to get some sort of, uh,
view from nowhere, some. Extra political, a social perspective
on the world and then theorize about it. Instead,
that one has to recognize that in theorizing, you
are embedded in a particular social historical context and
you're working with the ideas, ways of talking, ways
of thinking that are within that particular context. Um,
AND I think that's really significant, you know, Wittgenstein's
work in, in the philosophical investigations in particular, is
very, very useful in emphasizing this idea that our
modes of thinking and talking, uh, are very, very
attached to a particular form of life. Um, AND
that philosophical confusion arises precisely when we pretend otherwise.
We pretend that our words and our ideas come
from somewhere else or allow us to access some,
something outside of our particular social contexts. Um, AND,
and, and what I try and do by drawing
this Marx- Wittgenstein connection is to say, well, you
know, there's two significant things we maybe take from
this. One of this is that to understand something
like need, we can't look at it in the
abstract. We have to understand how need fits into
a particular form of life from the start. That's
where our ideas of needs come from. The second
is to say that, well, actually, you know, for
Marx, and he emphasizes this in a way that,
that, that Wittgenstein doesn't, is needs are themselves part
of that lived context, right? Like, we, we don't
start from sitting around, reasoning about needs, and then
encounter the world and have to actually meet those
needs. We start by eating and drinking and acting
in the world to meet needs. We start from
that practice that's needs orientated, and then we only
come later to this process of thinking and philosophizing.
And that I think really changes the way that
he approaches concepts like need um across quite a
lot of his work.
Yeah, no, no, it's, it's really amusing because I
mean what you're saying there and then of course
it could also be connected to other approaches in,
for example, sociology of science and philosophy of science,
but what you're saying there is something that unfortunately
many intellectuals, I mean it doesn't really matter if
they're from, if they're from the humanities or the
sciences. DO not really like to contend with very
much. I mean the fact that their thoughts and
ideas are embedded within and influenced by a particular
sociopolitical context, right? I mean sometimes people still tend
to have this view of, yeah, OK, so there's
ideas or there's I, I, I don't know, so,
uh, it's really, I, I, I mean, for people
who, who are influenced like you and I by
uh Marx and by anthropology, sociology, and so on,
it, it's a really difficult thing to conceive, but
sometimes people tend to put their, or have an
I. THAT intellectual stuff sits sort of above all
or can sit above all of these influences from
the social and political domain and sort of and
we can sort of reason ourselves in the Purely
reasoning way, let's say into our ideas without, uh,
with uh without regard for all of these social
and political influences,
right? I mean I think you're absolutely right, and
I, and I think, you know. Uh One of
the The, the, there's been a sort of intellectual
acceptance, I think, of some of these arguments, the
sort of embeddedness of thinking in a particular context
and a culture, a way of life, and so
on. But it's very hard to actually execute that
in practice. And this is something, you know, when
I, as I'm writing the book and typing these,
these pages, wondering to myself what, what's my particular
contextual embeddedness as I, as I do this activity.
But I think what Marx also reminds us is
this, this way of thinking of intellectual activity is
itself a product of our social order, right? Um,
THAT, you know, we think about intellectual activity as
separate from the world itself, precisely because we live
in an order that creates that way of thinking
about intellectual activity. And so, you know, we, uh,
we, we can't escape that either. If we, if
we really take his ideas seriously, you know, we
are also slightly bound to, to do so. And
he, and he's very good, you know, one of
the, the big, uh, sort of, uh, texts that
I focus on in the book. Is the German
ideology manuscripts, and I've got lots to say about
those if we wanna go on a, on a
tangent. But, you know, one of the things that
he does in the manuscripts is make fun of
these people lots and talks about, kind of, theoretical
castles in the sky and, you know, knights going
out to, and he has all these funny lines
about what the German, uh, young Hegelian German philosophers
are doing, imagining they can do exactly what, what
you describe about it is this sort of create
this academic world outside of. A lived social order,
but I, but I think, you know, we have
to embrace the, the challenge that Mark sets us
and recognize that it is a challenge to actually
think and write and be an intellectual in that
way.
So in this particular case then needs should be
understood as, as you put it in your book,
historically specific, socially constituted and deeply politically charged,
right? Mhm, YEAH, absolutely, and, and I think, you
know, each of those sort of, um, builds a
little bit on, on, on the previous one in
the sense that, you know, the idea that needs
are socially constituted is not. A, a, a new
idea, people have talked about the social construction of
needs or partial social construction of needs for a
long time. Um, AND, you know, we can all
recognize the ways in which needs evolve as our
society do, you know, we come to need things
that we didn't need before. Certain needs drop out
of the picture. You know, we need cars and
phones now and we never use things like that.
But what, what Marx then does is, is say,
well, it, it, you know, we have to look
at these social practices in a, in a historical
perspective. And by that is we have to understand
that social form as part of a, a, of
a particular horror historical form that has a historical
story. And what that adds, I think, to some
of the social constructivist views is he exposes it
to a kind of analysis, right? Um, RATHER than
just saying sort of everything's relative and everything's social
constructed and it just is what it is. It
has a particular historical form that's associated with real
historical processes that have happened that we can analyze,
we can look at the structures underneath all these
social processes and actually do some like concrete analysis
about. How needs have come to be the way
they are historically. Again, a car is a really
good example, right? Like, the fact that people need
cars didn't just happen because people decided one day
they did. We rebuilt our urban infrastructures and we
changed our way of life in fundamental ways such
that we find ourselves now dependent on a car.
Then the third element is to say, well, look.
These historical processes were political as well. Like, this,
this wasn't just sort of happy evolution of society.
This was struggle, this was often violence, this was
power, um, and that means that the, the order
that we find ourselves in has a kind of
political as well as a historical story behind it,
as well as a kind of political set of
consequences, like, um, you know, the fact that needs
have come to be the way they are benefits
certain people and places burdens on others. It puts
some people under the power of, of other people.
Um, AND we can assess those political consequences and
we can ask ourselves questions about those political consequences.
But also, precisely because needs were historically produced, they,
they will be again in the future. And precisely
because they were politically produced, they could be politically
produced otherwise in the future. So he opens up
a kind of contingency, um, and a way of
doing things otherwise as well, which opens up kind
of political possibility in a way that a kind
of naturalized picture of need just kind of marginalizes
and excludes.
Yeah, and it's very interesting because I mean, at
least as far as I understand it, some, at
least some people out there when they're trying to
approach needs from a philosophical perspective and even sometimes
informed by science, at least to some extent. They
are trying to ask, OK, so what are the,
the human needs? I mean they're trying to come
up with sort of a list of human needs,
but I mean from this more Marxist perspective of
needs as historically specific, socially constituted, and, and politically
charged. I mean that sort of question that stems
from uh um. Uh, STEMS from people trying to
come up with a universal list of human needs
that apply independent of context doesn't really make sense
anymore,
right?
Hm.
And, and, you know, it, it makes sense in
the sense that people do it for a reason,
as we talked about earlier, right, you know, it's
often by emphasizing the necessity and kind of factuality
of needs that we see them as having this
kind of normative power. But, you know, and, and
it also makes sense politically in that it's a
good thing to, you know, it's an effective thing
to do in politics. If we can persuade other
people that needs are in fact natural and given,
that can bring about political outcomes. And, and one
of the things I say in the book is
this isn't always bad, right, like, you know, there
have been times when people have appealed to these
naturalized ideas of needs in ways that have brought
about really good forms of political change. But there's
also been times where it's been quite bad, and
it can be bad and it has political dangers.
Um, AND, you know, what it, what it doesn't
do is make sense as the kind of purely
intellectual exercise that it's sometimes made into. Um, ONE
of the things I sort of write about a
little bit elsewhere, and I talk about very briefly
in the book, is, you know, the, the climate
change discourse at the moment and much of the
studies around climate change are increasingly appealing to sort
of needs-based pictures of how do we make sure
that future generations have got what they need in
order to live minimally decent lives. Um, ALL the
way up to the point of creating like a
kind of energy quota, saying we need X amounts
of energy in order to ensure that people can
lead decent lives. But all of that just takes
away the politics of what a decent life counts
as, and, and actually in doing so. Fixes a
particular way of life and a particular set of
needs as permanent and universal, even for these future
generations. And I think that that, that takes some
of the important political questions, but, well, actually, you
know, how fundamentally do we have to change our
way of life in order to meet the challenge
of the climate crisis gets kind of cut away
when we turn it into this purely empirical question.
Yeah, that's, that's interesting, but do you think that,
uh, I mean, from this point of view, uh,
from a more Marxist point of view, It would
be possible for us to in any way predict
or possibly predict what people in uh living in
a world where uh climate change has really uh
had a deep impact, not, not that it hasn't
already had some impact, but even more uh has,
has even, has been even more impactful than it
already has and. Um, WE need to vary, I,
I, I don't know to what extent, but probably
drastically change the way our, of life, our way
of life, our lifeways and our habits and customs
and all of that. I mean, I think it's
possible to predict if we are able to tell
the kinds of conditions, material conditions we'll live in,
what kinds of needs would develop in that context.
Yeah, and I think, I think maybe the word
I might. Push back on would be predict in
the sense that prediction is a very, like, empirical
exercise in terms of, like, we can just, you
know, read this empirical reality and determine a set
of needs. And I would maybe say something like
imagine, or politically imagine what it might be like,
which of course, you know, that imaginative exercise will
have to link to the facts, right, will link
to the way the world will be. But actually
it would involve something more creative and imagining a
different way of life and, you know, not only
will we have to predict it, we'll have to
enact it via politics, often involving struggle, um, you
know, we will have to make the possibilities of
a different way of life, you know, real by
struggling over them and contesting and, you know, fighting
with other people who might want to ring fence
a particular way of life. Um, AND so once
we put it in that slightly different political register,
um, it, it, it just changes the nature of
the debate from a purely empirical exercise about predicting
people's future needs to a political and imaginative one
about what do we want their way of life
to look like. Um, YEAH.
Right, uh, another thing that you touched on in
your book has to do with Judith Butler's theory
of gender and thinking of needs as performatives. Could
you tell us about that? I mean, uh, and
in what ways would, uh, Butler's theory of gender,
I mean, just for people to not be confused
there because she's talking about gender and then you
apply that to needs. I, I mean, what's the
connection there?
Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, one of the things
that, um, it, it, you know, first to stress
is that, that, that Butler's theory of performativity, the,
the language of the performative is a, is a
technical one drawn from the philosophy of language, and
it is unlike the sense of performativity that we
get when people say, oh, you're just doing it.
It's nothing like performance. It's a technical sense, and
it links to this idea that sometimes we use
words, um, that make the realities. It looks like
they just name. Um, AND, and, and we could
go down a rabbit hole with, with philosophy of
language, looking at different cases, but Butler's kind of
innovative move is to say that this way of
thinking about language applies to sex and gender. The
idea being that we usually think of sex as
something prior to gender. We have like biological sex,
or certainly this, this has historically been an orthodox
way of thinking about sex and gender. Um, WE
have biological sex and then we have the kind
of cultural construction of gender built on top, and
we have a kind of causal ordering or an
explanatory ordering that's something like that. And Butler flips
the whole thing around and says, well, actually our
ideas of natural sex are products of gender. They
are, when we name sex, we name male and
female, we are actually creating the realities we look
like we're just naming. Um, WE are making them
so in our social practices. And so there's this
really interesting kind of flip around of the kind
of causal order and temporal order, um, and explanatory
order of the concepts from. Uh, A kind of
natural to social, to a social to constructive naturalization.
Um, AND I think we can look at Marx's
way of talking about needs in much the same
way that, you know, even in our everyday life
and in much of our practices, needs look as
this kind of natural foundation, and we have this
kind of social order that's kind of secondary to
it or built on top of it. Whereas the
reality is the, is the opposite, that needs are
produced by this social order. Um, AND, you know,
so a, a butler provides a useful frame to
understand Marx, and I, I, lots of people who
like Marx really don't like Butler's work. So, the
chapter does quite a lot of work trying to
evidence this, uh, potential connection with this idea of
construction. And, and what, what I think construction is
a bad word because Butler themselves would, would, would
not use that language, um, this performativity, um. Uh,
IT, it is useful because Butler also uses that
to open up a political avenue to understanding biological
sex. Um, Butler's famous book, most famous book on
the topic is Gender Trouble, and this idea of
troubling is something I talk about in the book.
By switching around the way we think about these
concepts, we trouble them, we open them up to
new kinds of scrutiny. And then we can also
talk about them in ways that troubles them, that
not only, like, changes the way they are as
a concept or a thing, but also that problematizes
them, um, that challenges them, that opens them to
criticism. So I think both of these senses of,
or these uses of performativity, one as a kind
of conceptual one and one as a kind of
political troubling one, are things we can take from
Butler and that are echoed in different ways in,
in what Marx has to say about needs.
No, yeah, it's, it's really interesting because uh I
mean, and again that's one of the reasons why
I really appreciate um these scientific disciplines like anthropology
and sociology, because the anthropologists and sociologists, because they
deal with people embedded in a particular social and
cultural environment, they are much more open and. Much
more sophisticated understanding of these kinds of ideas than,
for example, biologists, and this is not to say
that of course biology is not legitimate, of course
it is a legitimate science, but when it comes
to, for example, people reacting to Butler's theory of
gender and gender as performative. Uh, ONE of the
most immediate responses that, uh, one gets from, uh,
no, uh, uh, from scientists that do not come
from the social sci sciences like biologists is that,
oh, that's just, uh, post-modernist nonsense. I mean that,
that, that is just pseudoscience or whatever, but actually,
Uh, um, I mean, within, uh, within the context
of philosophy of language and also if you look
at it from a more socio-cultural standpoint, it makes
sense and, uh, maybe, I think that maybe scientists
should be a little, um, or um sci scient
bio biological scientists should be a little bit more
open to it also because philosophy of language can
help you develop. Develop a more sophisticated view of
even the theory and conceptualization within uh biology, in
this case, the biology of section, uh, sex and
gender, I guess. I mean, at least that's uh
how I view it, so.
Yeah, I mean, I, I, and, and, and I
think there are really good examples as well as
bad examples, and I think there's a lot that
many different disciplines can learn from philosophy of language.
I mean, there's really interesting things in physics. I
think it's Karen Barard who, who talks about performativity
and links it to, uh, the, um, kind of
quantum physics in, in, in really interesting ways. So
there are, you know. Ways in which these ideas
um have permeated out towards the natural sciences, um,
and I think, you know, one of the things
that is fair to say about Butler, and I
talk a bit about the book is that in
their work. Um, SOME of the biological stuff. It
becomes difficult to explain and has been a long
source of debate, um, and they've worked very hard
to push back against some of those criticisms and
the body plays a really, really important role in,
in their more recent work, um, and, you know,
actually their, all their work really, the body has
always been there but just in a different way
than the biologists like to imagine it's just this
kind of fixed biological thing that we just know.
The body is playing a role in these performative
processes. Um, I do think Butler is a little
bit guilty about marginalizing some of the material stuff,
and I can talk more about that if, if,
if we're interested. But one of the things I
think is really interesting with Marx is that for
him, labor is always a really key part of
these practices, right? Because, you know, I said there
was this, this flip around where we move from
seeing the natural and then the social, to seeing
the socialist come out explaining natural, but that social
is not like. Just social ideas in people's heads
or culture as something that's totally outside of the
natural world, those social practices are people working on
the world in, you know, real physical ways, human
bodies moving in space. Um, AND so from the
start, you know, matter is there, it's just not
there as a kind of fixed thing outside of
the social, it's there as part of these social
practices. Um, SO, I, you know, I think there's
ways in, in Marx that there are this, this
kind of material and social story of, are always
intertwined from the start.
Right, right. So, uh, another question that you explore
in your book has to do with what needs
do in a capitalist society. So what do they
actually do, what functions do they serve?
Yeah, and I, and I think this is one
of the ways in which Marxist attempt to politicize
needs. Is really, really interesting because he sees, you
know, the, the, the key to, to the critiquing
needs as really, really understanding the political processes within
a particular social order and historical order that can
be analyzed. And for him, the kind of key
element is, is establishing dependence, in particular the dependence
of wage labor on selling their, their labor power
for a wage in order to live. Um, AND
the, the, the way the book kind of tells
that story is, is with Marx's account of so-called
primitive accumulation, uh, uh, towards the end of Capital
Volume One. And one of the things we can,
way to read that story is, so, you know,
we had this sort of pre-capitalist social order where
needs meeting was done in, in, in a kind
of small status groups that were very, very relational,
very, very known, and that capitalism came along and
kind of wiped out these status groups, and it
created, um, a system where we had individuals who
the only way they could survive was to sell
their labor for a wage. And one of the
interesting things about the start of that story, and
if we read capital in this way, is, you
know, if we start with marks on simple accumulation
or sorry, simple exchange at the the at the
beginning of capital. He has this, this story of,
of commodity exchange, and in that story, um, you
know, where we were just buying and selling commodities,
needs don't really feature. They don't appear at all.
Um, WE just buy and sell from each other,
and what, what you're doing with the product I
sell to you, whether you're using it to meet
a need or to, you know, just meet some
desire or what, I, I've not, I know, the
seller doesn't know. And actually in the social processes
of exchange at that level, needs don't exist. And
the way I describe it in the book is
that if we imagine capitalist society in this way,
needs disappear, they are forgotten in, in a certain
part of the kind of capitalist story of accumulation.
Um, AND where, where do they reappear? Well, they
reappear with this wage contract. They reappear once we've
created this situation where people have to sell their
labor for a wage. It's only at that point
where the capitalists and, you know, in the worker
in their contract have to calculate, well, what's a
fair wage? And so Marx uses his, his, his
sort of classic theory of value where we think
of, you know, this is the labor required to
reproduce the commodity that is the laborer themselves and
their work. And so needs have kind of been
forgotten, only to be remembered within this particular point,
um, of the, of the kind of story of
capital. And the way I describe this in the
book is, is, is almost a kind of weaponization
of need, right? We've torn apart these previous social
processes. We've created a situation where the only way
needs come back into the social story is when
we have this exchange of labor power, where, where,
where the worker is fundamentally dependent on the capitalists
in order to survive, in order to have any
kind of form of need at all. And so
it's at that point that needs become crystallized into
this new social form as the worker's subsistence. Um,
AND we can talk more exactly how that, that
works, but, you know, it, it's that critical point
of establishing dependence that's the core of the kind
of political story of need for Marx.
Mhm. Uh, IN the book you also talk about
the method of representation, representation with a, with a
hyphen there when it comes to needs. So what
is that method about and what can we learn
from it?
Yeah, and I think the way you put it
is, you know, Marx wants to tell this political
story. He wants to say, you know, once we
understand needs for performative, we understand them as politically
created, well, what does critique come in? Where does
a social critic enter this story and what can
they do? And part of the sort of classic
problem and why people have often appealed to these
extra social accounts of these is to say, well,
look, if needs are just socially and politically constituted,
how can they be used as standards of critique
against a particular social order? If capitalism meets needs.
Then how can they also be used to critique
the capitalist social order. And I think what Marx
cleverly does, and, and this is how I read
Capital and how others have read Capital, is to
say, well, look, if we're actually, let's take this
story seriously, let's take this idea that, you know,
um, if we need this external standard to de-critique,
what we're saying is that if we look from
things purely within the worldview of capital, we look
from things internally. Then everything looks great. Everything looks
peachy. The story is perfect. We can create this
kind of perfect internal story where capitalism is insulated
from critique. And you can read capital is, is
taking this idea seriously. Let, let's tell this story
and imagine, you know, creating a peachy looking, rosy
picture of capital. And quickly things fall to pieces,
right? The story just doesn't make sense, it collapses
under its own self-contradictions. And the whole point there
is to say that actually, you know, we don't
need this external standard, that actually it's all there
in front of us in the world. Critical resources
to challenge our existing social order are there if
we care to look. And the only reason we
don't see them is because a story has been
told that marginalizes them or excludes them or hides
them. Presents them a particular way so that we
don't see those critical resources, hence re-presentation. Well, look,
if there are these presentations out there and he's
focusing in particular on the kind of political economists
of his time. If there are these presentations out
there that make things look OK, even if they're
full of all their problems and self-contradictions, they're a
story that tries to do that, why don't we
tell a different story that brings out the critical
elements, the failings, the contradictions, the gaps, the possibilities
for struggle, the impositions of power. So representation then
is not to draw out the critical standard from
the outside, it's to present the world in front
of us in a different way so as to
bring out this kind of critical perspective.
So earlier I asked you what kinds of approaches
to needs would lead to normative consequences. I mean,
would generate normative forces, but do you think that
approaching needs as neutral acts of pure description, can
it serve the interests of oppressive regimes actually?
Mhm. And I'm, I mean, and I think this
idea of pure description, is a really interesting one.
Like, what do we mean by a pure description?
And I think Marx and Wittgenstein would both say
this whole idea of a pure description is a
fantasy. It is a, is a social fantasy we
create within a particular social and historical order that
imagines we can just tell things purely descriptively. When
we describe, we do. So as socially embedded beings
with a particular sort of consciousness. We describe four
reasons and in ways that invoke a particular social
order that isn't neutral, right, that isn't pure itself,
that favors some interests over others, has struggle, and
so on. So, once we kind of explode this
idea of pure description as a, as a kind
of philosophical possibility, what happens when we do imagine
that we could do pure description, we present things
as pure description. And I think Marx's way of
telling that story is something like, well, look, all
this does is just disappear the politics that's there,
the struggle, the harms, the power. Pure description just
masks all that stuff that's going on to present
itself as pure and neutral. Um, SO that neutralizes
politics. It removes possibilities of struggle, it makes things
seem necessary when in fact they are contestable. And
in that sense they can serve oppressive regimes because
if you can successfully present something as a pure
description, then you can take away possibilities for conflict,
dissent, you can, you can make power look natural,
things like that.
Yeah, so, uh, I have one final question then.
What would you say are the main implications of
this Marxian approach to needs for the contemporary politics
of need? I mean, looking at how the politics
of need presents itself contemporarily, what would be the
implications of this more Marxian approach?
Um, AND I think there's, there's two main ones
I'll draw out here. Um, YOU know, one of
them, I think it, it, it is conceptual, but
it's a conceptual move that opens up the politics,
and that is, you know, in so many of
contemporary needs theory and it, and it needs talk
more generally in, you know, you know, political spheres
in practice. The question's always driven towards, you know,
what. What do people really need? What are the
facts of needs, and what do we do about
those facts? And what I think Marx pushes us
to do is to ask different sorts of questions
like what had to happen for needs to appear
in the way that they do to us today.
And when things happen that way, what politically led
to that happening and, and, and what were the
consequences for us? Who wins, who loses, who gets
harmed, who gets power, things like that. Whose interests
are served. And then, you know, that opens up
questions of how things can do differently. So to
sort of switch around from what needs fundamentally are
to what does our talk about needs and our
way of thinking about needs do in the world,
and what, you know, should we accept it as
it is? Should we try to change it. I
think that's one element. A second element is probably
the centrality of work, and I spoke about that
very briefly with this idea of the wage contract.
And I, and I think there are, there are
others who have sort of emphasized, uh, elements of
the politics of need in different ways. And what
I think Marx's analysis does is, is to reveal
the, you know, key to getting a, a really
good critical perspective on the politics of needs is
to understand the kind of underlying structures of power
within that politics, you know, how do those structures
come about, who wins, who loses. Um, AND, and
his part of that story really centers on work,
the role of needs in, um, this, this, in
rendering us dependent on work to live, and how
that not only. HAS an important role in, in,
in kind of uh. Uh, CREATING a kind of
dependence on work, um, but how that also shapes
our needs. And, you know, we can see that
in the world around us, how often our needs
are shaped by the needs of work, our education,
our healthcare, all these sorts of things are often
really strongly centered around, uh, the role of work
in shaping our needs. And what I think Marx
does is bring that work story back into the
critical conversation, re-centers it, and that I think provides
a really useful kind of critical perspective on the
contemporary politics of need.
Mhm. But, but I mean the way we understand
work and the implications that ask for needs in
our contemporary society, I, I mean that, that, that's
again, uh, how work. Um, WORKS, I mean, so
to speak, uh, um, I mean, uh, how work
is done in this, uh, capitalist system, right? I
mean, because in other kinds of social organizations, uh,
I, I don't know if we lived in a
hunter-gatherer society or a hor a horticulturalist society or
Um, an agricultural feudalist society, the way we would
understand work and the need we would attach to
it would again be, uh, contextual. I mean, and
it would be different from how we understand it
in this capitalist context, correct?
Yeah, that's, I mean, and, and much of what
we've said today about, about need could probably be
said about work as well. Work itself is a
particular historical form that. Takes a particular kind of
kind of shape in in what we might call
the work society, um, and our understanding of what
work is and its role in our life is,
is, is shaped by that society and needs is
a really big part of that story. Um, AND
I think what the, and it brings into conversation,
you know, there is a, an active conversation in,
in political practice and in political theory about the
work society, what it does, and, you know, looking
at sort of post-work theories, which are increasingly prominent.
And I think what the, the Marxian approach to
me does very effectively is to bring these two
kind of discourses into, into useful conversation and say,
you know, one of the really important ways we
have to understand the work society is to understand
how it's created a particular sort of human life
with a particular set of needs. Those needs feel
very natural and appear very natural, and in fact
they, you know, they are important right now. It's
not to say that they don't matter, they do
matter, but precisely because we are historical beings who
live in the world that we do, these things
are really important. We can't just pretend they aren't
there. But they could be different, and then we
have to open these critical questions about, well, look,
what kind of society might generate a different sort
of human life and a different set of needs?
In what ways might that release us from relationships
of power, independence that structure our, our current way
of living and, and, and so on.
Yeah, which is interesting because I think that in
a sense it can also free you, free us
from the idea that, OK, there is this set
of human needs that are universal and are independent
of context, and we will always need to care
about these set of needs that we are currently
attached to. But I mean, it frees us from
that idea and it allows for us to perhaps
think more of how we could reshape society economically,
politically, socially in ways that we could construct new
needs and in our needs that, I mean, even
if you want to put it in those terms,
that would be better for us.
Hm, yeah, and, and, and, and yeah, we, we,
we could probably have another hour on what better
means. Uh
YEAH, sure, that, that's what, that's the reason why
I said if you want to put it in
those terms,
right? Yeah, and I, I certainly think we can,
what we can do is look at the political
consequences and realities of our existing sets of needs,
judge those consequences, and, and, and reach for something
different if we, if we judge them negatively. Um,
AND also there's big questions about who we is
here. I mean, Marx himself would, you know, as
part of this very socially embedded perspective, would also
have, have, have, have stressed, you know, the, the
class-orientated nature of our perspectives, right? In the sense
that, you know, there is no view from nowhere,
there's also no view from a class nowhere. You're,
you're talking either as bourgeois or as proletarian, and,
and so, in a sense, there's a way in
which what Marx is trying to do in capital
is not. Produce a better theory than the bourgeois
political economists as he would frame them, but to
present the proletarian version of that same theory, um,
he calls himself the theoretician of the proletarian class
at one point. Um, SO I think there's are
really important questions here about, uh, you know, how
we understand where we look at these political processes
from, how we judge them, and then how we
reach something else. What I think Marx really achieves
is opening up a set of political questions that
are, that were previously closed down and, and opening
a kind of. Form of scrutiny that in my
mind is more necessary now than ever with things
like climate change, with the, you know, increasing role
I see of, of needs in our political discourses
with things like the challenges to contemporary welfare states,
um, with things like aging populations, you know, given
how central needs are to so much of our
political discourse, we also need to be asking these
kind of critical political questions about the discourse of
need, and I think Marx provides some really useful
openings to do that.
Great. So the book is again Marx and the
Politics of Need, and I of course we'll be
leaving a link in the description of the interview.
And Dr. Boss, apart from the book, would you
like to tell people where they can find you
and your work on the internet?
Absolutely. So I'm at Queen Mary, um, so I
have a page at the Queen Mary website, but
I also have, uh, my own personal website. If
you just Google Doctor George Bass, it comes up
pretty, pretty quickly in the, in the solutions. Um,
AND you can see stuff there. I try and
take some of this stuff forward in the Leverhulme
project, talking about the role of needs talk in
more kind of contemporary politics. Um, AND the book
is also open access, um, I, I should, I
should note, so it's free to read.
Great, so thank you so much for taking the
time to come on the show. It's been a
real pleasure to talk with you.
Well, thank you so much, it's been great and
uh I've really appreciated this chat, it's been great
fun.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerruinnai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor, Michel
Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and Hal
Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel Cerri,
Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran, David
Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono Correa.
Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam Hunt,
Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Junior.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Gelbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas Stink,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.